وكما اوضح مراسلنا قبل قليل الوقت يلعب ضد
اوكرانيا وهي كذلك وجهه نظر امريكيه
نقلتها نيويورك تايمز عن وزيره الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابقه كونداليزا رايس ووزير
الدفاع الامريكي الاسبق روبرتغيتس
المسؤولين الامريكيان السابقان طلبات دول
النيتو بدعم عسكريا اكبر لاوكرانيا رغم ان
اجمالي المساعدات الغربيه العام الماضي
بلغ 120 مليار دولار ومن بينها اكثر من 24
مليار دولار مساعدات عسكريه امريكيه تطور
المعارك في بخمود وصل لدار لصالح الروس
زادت من دعاوى تسليح اوكرانيا ولكنها قد
تؤجل بعض الدعم من جهه اخرى فا ايطاليا
مثلا لن تتخذ اي قرار بتقديم مساعده
عسكريه لاوكرانيا قبل فبراير المانيا ايضا
ليس لديها خطط لارسال الدبابات وايضا ان
كانت تفكر بريطانيا لم تقرر بعد ارسال
دبابات تشالنجر ان كان سيلنسكي اكد الامر
اليوم لكن هذا الامر يعني ان المواجهه مع
روسيا مستقبلا قد تكون ورده وارده رايس
وجيتس يؤكد ذلك وهنا يجب على الناتو دعم
اوكرانيا باسلحه ثقيله ونوعيه للحد من
قدره روسيا في مواجهه كبرى محتمله لكن
تبقى معضله اخرى تواجه القوات الاوكرانيه
الاسلحه الغربيه العامله في الجبهات كلمه
فعاليات ثقيله مثلا هذه هي المنظمات
المعقده تحتاج الى عمليات اصلاح وصيانه
متكرره لكثافه استخدامها وعمليات الصيانه
لا تتم الا على بعد مئات الاميال من
الجبهات وتحديدا في دول النيته ما يعني
غيابها عن ساحات القتال في وقت طويل مثلا
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا تقوماني
بصيانه الاسلحه المتبرع بها لاوكرانيا في
بولندا واضافه الى ليتوانيا التي تبعد عن
جبهه خيرسون اكثر من الفا 24 50 كلم